Justice League is finally here and you
know what that means bring on the fun
discussions bring on the fan discussions
talking about Justice League DC Comics
Marvel Comics so everybody can have fun
in the discussion below and not
perpetuate a very toxic environment that
does reality right now
[Music]
Justice League so Justice League is
directed by Zack Snyder who's to us
directing credit in the credits it's the
film adaptation among the DC Cinematic
Universe of the Justice League the DC
heroes coming together and forming you
know pretty much DC Avengers so maybe
the Avengers are Marvel Justice League
expect it's just saying in this story
there is a villain called Steppenwolf
who's coming to earth to do you know bad
guy things can't have spoilers here so
Bruce Wayne and Diana Prince that would
be Batman and Wonder Woman have to go
around and get a team together to fight
this so Earth doesn't you know
die I've been looking forward to this
man how can we not be looking forward to
this when the Avengers happen and
started a cinematic universe and we
learned DC was doing theirs who didn't
have a boner for Justice League that's
awesome some bumps along the way among
the Cinematic Universe for some fans but
I'll admit it you're morbidly curious
aren't you so what I liked about this
movie is if there is a character that
you liked in a previous movie in the DC
Cinematic Universe and they're in this
movie what you liked about them is
generally speaking intact I mean there's
some character growth in this one
because this movie takes place after the
other movies you can tell Batman for one
has grown a bit and they address that in
this movie but point is the essence of
him Wonder Woman what you liked about
her that's intact let the newcomers
flash cyborg Aquaman I'm interested in
curious about all their movies I don't
know if cyborg is actually getting his
standalone movie the flash was
definitely the comic relief's there's
more comedy tied in with him than most
other characters he even says in one of
the trailers he was like I don't get
into fights I just run really fast and
push people over can we think about the
flash you're like yeah that's true what
if he goes up against someone really
powerful really fast he hasn't dealt
with that yet but when he ran when he
was Halle ass and that Speed Force is
coming off of him in the form of
lightning it just looks really cool I
didn't actually remember that it wasn't
yellow I'm used to being yellow a fan of
the flash TV show and it never once
bothered me I'm just saying people are
entitled to their nitpicks that would
have been one but it was also Arthur
curry Jason Momoa as Aquaman I will say
of the characters for me he's the one
that kind of got left in the background
a little bit he certainly has a couple
of fun moments of action which you saw
in the trailer I mean when it was when
he's riding that parademon tide that's
in the trailer and I don't like it when
trailers spoil something that would have
been so cool to see in the movie for the
first time turns out that trailer in
this movie they did that but from the
trailer I thought it was just gonna be a
dude with one lines like mom man yeah in
the simplest way I can explain it I
liked his personality the personality of
the characters in this movie actually
supersedes the action stage
also cyborg the CGI on cyborg is the
most noticeable more noticeable in some
scenes more than others to dude is 90 is
on percents AGI so there's no getting
around it and it's not completely
noticeable all the time the time and
effort spent on cyborg developing his
character and there's a fair amount of
it he's kind of a newbie his powers are
developing we can forgive those moments
of noticeable CGI with cyborg character
comes first and this being a mix of
heroes I do enjoy that mix of heroes you
have your rookies who got their powers
not too long ago and you have your
seasoned veterans there are some scenes
where you're like diets it that's notice
about CGI cyborg but it doesn't change
the fact that in the last act when I was
seeing them all fight together I was
like the Justice League just happened
it's really neat it's an experience that
I can say I was there I was alive I was
reviewing movies I was watching movies
when that happened for the first time I
was here asks for the flowers this movie
was supposed to be something like two
hours 45 minutes and it was recently
sliced down to be two hours or I think
if the mandate was less than two hours
of clocks in it like an hour 59 minutes
and it does show especially in the first
act of the movie this setup you can tell
it's like they're supposed to be so much
more information here even going into
the second act of the movie that was
more noticeable in the first act there's
even one scene where it's just like
something's gonna it's done now like
okay something's missing isn't there so
the pacing in some time blocks in the
movie it's a bit choppy so I'm looking
forward to seeing the director's cut or
extended edition special edition
whatever they're gonna call it it comes
out on blu-ray it'll probably happen
also there are a couple of instances
where they talk about certain things
that given previous movies in the
cinematic universe couldn't have
happened the way they said it happened
so the chronology is starting to get
fudged up a little bit the villain
Steppenwolf I thought he was fine and
functional for his part you feel like
you're dealing with the middleman a bit
you're like okay between the Justice
League and Darkseid I guess there's you
can't help but have the kid inside you
jump up and down into the dark side but
it was fine and functional when he was
on screen when he was not on screen I
kind of forgot about him first and
foremost the point of all of it is
seeing your heroes come together and for
that I felt they did a good job with
that
Steppenwolf can take a back seat if they
heroes get a front seat guys in the end
Justice League was a very good time for
me so it wasn't perfect there's some
tonal issues in the movies I'm pacing
issues in the movie some of the hammer
didn't really land some of it actually
surprisingly landed one thing that
happens in here especially cracked me up
I know that people were getting worried
like
what Perry White's not gonna be in the
movie Lex Luthor's not gonna be a part
of the plot when you look at it though
it's like where would Perry White fit in
here we're with Lex Luthor really fit in
here so I'm glad they took him out a
comic book fan and me was pleased and
the movie fan in me was entertained and
that will say Justice League is a good
time no alcohol required
yeah the movies better than Suicide
Squad but this is why I hate ratings all
right guys so Justice League have you
seen it what did you think about it or
let's let's theorize here not that I
hold Rotten Tomatoes is the end-all
be-all but it does make for a fun thing
what do you think the tomato meter for
Justice League is going to be by the end
of the weekend whatever it is whatever
you think comment below let me know and
as always if you like what you've seen
here and you want to see more click
right here to see more
[Music]